[Music]
Eric don't do it you've worked so hard
don't wreck it now come on dr. Berg do
it dr. Berg put it down what are you
doing come on you don't know that this
is gonna cause a long slow painful death
take your chances
dr. Berg you know that's gonna be bad
for your sleep and you know how much you
need your sleep
come on we're all gonna die a something
that's gonna interfere with your fat
burning' for the next 72 hours do it
you're gonna be craving it again in the
morning just a little bit this one time
don't fall for the trap put it down just
know it
so I know this might be hard to believe
but some people are actually addicted to
carbohydrates I know it's it's pretty
strange isn't it well I want to talk
about what happens in the brain when
someone has an addiction to carbs okay
there's a little Center it's a little
nucleus a tiny little cell body called
the nucleus accumbens and it's deep in
the brain if you were to kind of just go
right in this way at this level it's way
deep inside there right in the center
and this nucleus is part of the reward
system of the body it uses dopamine as
its main neurotransmitter also gaba and
serotonin and these neurotransmitters
are intimately involved with creating
this pleasure sensation so when this
nucleus is stimulated through certain
recreational drugs alcohol tobacco sex
exercise and sugar we'll come back to
this one these are the triggers that
cause this little cell body to release
these neurotransmitters to give you the
sensation these do not give you the
sensation directly they do it indirectly
through this system right here so the
pleasure that you feel from any of these
is really your own body's chemicals okay
now sugar is a really big trigger for
this nucleus right here on an MRI when
people take sugar this Center lights up
like a laser okay so it's a it's
involved in the release of dopamine in
pleasure and people get pleasure by
consuming refined carbohydrates because
the refined carbohydrates turn red and
sugar pretty quickly now the problem is
too much of this the stimulus downgrades
the receptor for dopamine and now you're
not satisfied so you need a little bit
more you need a little bit more until
eventually you create an addiction all
right now the difference between an
addiction and a craving is in the
addiction the consequences don't bother
you much anymore you're just going to go
ahead and do it without the thought of
the consequences so some people have
high willpower and some people have low
power I'm going to talk about how to
increase your willpower
and part of it is improving this
physical structure in your brain
all right so number one you want to
avoid certain environments that expose
you to sugar okay so I'm talking about
restaurants mainly or even if you go to
Disney World into these other places
there's like there's so much sugar
around so you want to limit your
exposure to environmental sugar okay so
that's number one and number two you
don't want to keep any sugar in the
house if your spouse if your kids like
sugar you're gonna have to all come to a
group agreement and if they're gonna
keep it you know in the house they're
gonna have to hide it very well because
you just don't want to be exposed to it
you don't want to have it in the
cupboard waiting for you and talking to
you and in calling out to you at late at
night okay number three get your
pleasure from being healthy and looking
healthy and with that you want to do
healthy keto and then a fasting I put a
link for those of you that are new but
many of you are already on that and you
are getting a lot of pleasure from being
healthy when you do healthy keto in a
minute fasting your mood elevates your
cognitive function improves okay so you
are gonna be generally happier compared
to when your blood Sugar's are crashing
you want even sugar you're like roller
coastering all the time with low blood
sugar problems and I already talked
about keto and I have being essential
but because this will reset the nucleus
accumbens because you're taking away the
thing that's creating the receptor
problem and so now the receptor will go
back to normal and then when your body
starts burning ketones your brain loves
it and these ketones will help heal the
damage in the brain because this is
located in the part of the brain called
the limbic system where the body can
regenerate that that brain tissue so
that's that's fortunate and lastly a
vitamin b1 has a potential to increase
your dopamine levels by taking b1 within
minutes you'll just feel like a huge
stress relief and calmness part of that
is because the increase in dopamine
alright guys thanks for watching
dr. Berg you know how that gave you
rumblies in the tummy and that was
embarrassing
oh this is gonna work lunch meat lunch
loaf luncheon loaf no one's gonna want
to crave that so we'll just put this
away
hey guys real quick I have a new healthy
keto eating plan for you just go to dr.
Berg calm it's right on the front page I
put a link down below download it it's
free check it out